our first heat warning of the year more
on that
outside that begins tomorrow that is for
the las vegas valley now this heat
warning is for areas
below 4000 feet so notice the mountains
and those of you in lincoln county you
are not in that heat warning so these
might be the places to go
to actually cool off and escape the heat
here are highs for tomorrow
las vegas 106 green valley 108 laughlin
112. kiefner had that same reaction
119 for death valley and this is
tomorrow i think
actually thursday we can reach 120 for
death valley
for tomorrow that is the reason why we
have the heat warning here are heat
impacts all right
heat illness is going to be high
especially if you work outside
burn paws for pets that will remain high
if you take your pets out during the
heat of the day
remember the morning hours and after
sundown fill the meat of your hands on
the ground
to make sure that their paws don't get
burned if it's too hot for your palms
don't take them out hot in the car too
pets go inside
kids go inside with you when you go out
when you leave the car behind
hot overnight that's going to remain low
so that's good so at least the recovery
or night is not
bad in the summer this gets high because
we're in the 90s for overnight lows i've
got a lot to talk about
and a lot to show you neighborhood by
neighborhood as far as your temperatures
go that's all coming up in your most
accurate forecast
after the break